I could not get Rachel green off of my
back for the life of me that's Jennifer
Aniston opening up during the Hollywood
Reporter's drama actress roundtable
about trying to escape the sitcom role
that shot her to start him I could not
escape
yeah just Rachel from friends just
Rachel from friends and I'd be like and
it's on all the time and you're just
like stop playing this big show I I
completely just fought with myself and
and who I was in this industry for
forever because it was just constantly
about trying to prove that I was more
than that in a portion of the interview
not included in the video clip Aniston
explains that filming the 2002 drama D
the good girl was the first time she
really got to quote shed whatever the
Rachel character was just seeing have
you ever been doing a Bible study for
about loving Jesus yeah I kind of like
my nights to myself well maybe you'll
have a night after night of eternal
Hellfire hold yourself the 51 year old
actress adds that while the experience
was a relief she remembers quote the
panic that set over me thinking oh god I
don't know if I can do this maybe
they're right maybe everybody else is
seeing something I'm not seeing which is
you are only that girl in the New York
apartment with the purple walls oh
that's interesting
Jenn continues that she was almost doing
it for herself just to see if she could
play a character other than Rachel quote
it was terrifying because you're doing
it in front of the world
but despite the actresses desire to put
Rachel green behind her what she and
Friends co-star Lisa Kudrow recently
chatted about their nostalgia for the
beloved sitcom and varieties actors on
actors series I loved stumbling on a
friends episode in like 15 minutes worth
of bloopers that we sat there at the
computer like two nerds watching these
bloopers laughing at ours
think I've done it too
[Music]